der nächste es auch wer sehr klassisch
und zwar will moneypenny gerne wissen
was macht miguel pablo in der zukunft
mehr hat die kristallkugel gesagt das
mega pablo tatsächlich herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video wir
machen heute was was sehr wichtige für
viele youtuber denn viele youtuber haben
glaube ich nicht nur an ihren plan fürs
leben durch da ja die macht youtuber den
hier trat ein bisschen geld manche der
viel geld gebiet wissen nicht genau was
sie danach so machen wenn youtube vorbei
deswegen gibt es heute für alle youtube
die sich auch die frage stellen was
mache ich eigentlich wenn youtube dabei
ist dieses video denn heute überlegen
wir uns max und ich hallo was youtuber
in der zukunft zu machen wer in der
kanalisation eventuell beim arbeitsamt
auseinander vorstellig werden muss und
wer weiterhin bereich bleibt und
deutschland richtig kraft geben sagte er
wir überlegen uns das zumeist eher sagen
wie sein wird weil wir wissen dass wir
tatsächlich recht ich bin leider mit
dumme missgeburt und haben vergessen
dass wir es tatsächlich von wissen ja
wir haben live info von der
kristallkugel bekommen von mal wanne die
hat die kristallkugel für die youtube
zukunft bei sich zu hause stehen ich
habe jetzt wieder gefragt über welche
lieber wir die zukunft herausfinden
sollen und wir legen erstmal so fangen
doch einfach mal mit einem vorschlag von
ft mit das läuft die fragt
selbstverständlich nach dem größten
künstler deutschland nach einer person
die million integrativ jungs und mädels
auf den richtigen weg geleitet hat die
redet selbstverständlich von apa red
weißt du was ich ganz ehrlich glaube ich
glaube upgrade wird grundschullehrer
ohne wird ich glaube der betont
schullehrer der denk dich irgendwann ob
jeweils quast was habe ich eigentlich in
den letzten 15 jahren meines lebens
gemacht ich respekt für das was er sich
aufgebaut hat habe ich vielleicht dann
sicher viel arbeit reingesteckt aber er
hat eben auch ein paar sachen gemacht
die nicht so sauber sind und das wird
ihm irgendwann auffallen und dann wird
er glaube ich sagen das ist ja mal
irgendwo einem bach in hamburg und denke
ich so leben du bist so ein kleiner go
will ich mich fit fühle ich mich fit
da denkt er sich doch eigentlich wenig
nicht [ __ ] und dann wird der
grundschullehrer also meine meinung er
will grund schwerer was das ist
der radikale these ich würde er auch das
kiffen wie nicole verkäufer euro gut
vorstellen dass dubais arbeitet oder
sowas und seine jungs zur fertig bevor
ihr könnt meine kommentaren für unsere
region abstimmen welche vision etwa die
formaxx oder von mir für
wahrscheinlicher halte die erste
optionen sind grundschullehrer oder
sneaker verkäufer der nächste vorschlag
kommt von nessa und die möchte gerne
wissen was ist die zukunft von rewe
zufällig weiß ich das als ob wir
wirklich mal war die bescheid wieder
richtig genau wie wird irgendwann in
eine klinik eingewiesen und einen
cholerischen anfälle unter kontrolle
bringen sein wissen dass er das land hat
wenn man andere choleriker weitergeben
und wurden modell entwickeln mit dem
andere leute quasi mit ihren
aggressionen umgehen kann also koalition
choleriker coaching richtig richtig tief
als dass die wenn die natur aus ganz
einfach übernehmen wir wissen schon wie
es ihr terminkalender so wahrscheinlich
ist es so vorprogrammiert dass ältere
bietet dem entwickler möchten durch ich
würde mich ganz ehrlich als inhaber
eines live über tatmotiv ich kann sich
auch sein
auf jeden fall für prädestiniert ist
natürlich mit seiner selbständigkeit
choleriker coaching und so passt es
natürlich wenn man sich leute einstellt
auch raum für weitere sachen also
vielleicht macht er auch weiß irgendwann
waren oder er wird immobilienmakler
verkaufte immobilien in köln fertigte
das können auch verstärkt und
realistisch schätzt nächste vorschlag
kommt von lukla girl und heißt kuchen tv
was vielen tv ist ricky man weiß gar
nicht so sehr was macht also das
studiert ja ich glaub nicht mehr genäht
presse
realschulabschluss wenn ich zuerst
täuscht niveau bei der hat eine
ausbildung als wir begonnen was und
wurde darauf geworfen wenn mich nicht
alles täuscht wahrscheinlich überleben
kufen rot wird der tiere gemacht aber
bei kuchen tv ist wirklich echt
interessieren als irgendeine macht weil
ja die sonst sagen also somit seine fig
die welt einstellung kommt man halt nur
verträglich mit dem was er macht durch
die welt konzeption einstellung nur
durch die welt wenn du damit geld macht
so einen spaß zu haben wenn du anders
irgendwie arbeitet und so drauf ist dass
du ihrem mit ins kraftwerk wer kommt
dass das glaube ich echt schwierig ich
weiß wer wird untersagt doch er wird
neuer rüdiger hoffmann oder mit leute
das einzige was sie bei kodi war
wirklich vorstellen kann ist dass er
reich bürger wird die beste der besten
gefallen ist ich würde reich bürger und
zwei für die existenz der bundesrepublik
deutschland an alles kann irgendwie
tatsächlich vorstellen dass wir
irgendwas macht wohl so anhänger um sich
schart also irgendwie irgendwelche leute
um sich herum hat ich sage brief dass
der nächste ist auch wer sehr klassisch
und war will moneypenny gerne wissen was
macht mega pablo in der zukunft das auch
sehr interessante ideen wirst du
loslegen möchte ein
[Musik]
ich glaube er stirbt an einer überdosis
der mit seinem letzten youtube man
gekauft hat könnte ausleihen leute
dürfen sich wirklich übernehmen also wir
das kommt nicht von uns dass wir gerade
sein keyboard case entwicklung das kommt
nicht von uns graffiti publikum zu gehör
kommt nicht von uns eine sache der tfx
auto gewaschen wurde es ist eine der
lustigsten sachen aller zeiten auf
youtube mehr die kristallkugel gesagt
das mega pablo tatsächlich arbeitslos
wird und sozialhilfeempfänger das klingt
jetzt gemein ich sage ich dass ich mir
das wünsche auf gar keinen fall mehr
pablo hat auch sein eigenes ding gemacht
hat aber ich glaub echte zu seiner
zukunft
okay du gehst möchte klar wissen was die
zukunft von kacarevic da muss man
einfach ganz kurz zeitweilig schon im
letzten video dran war die olle
pornodarstellerin 100 profis wie wird
die frauenrechtsaktivistin möchte von
allen guten geistern verlassen merkt was
hier der welt angetan hast du von allen
guten gar nicht ok naja vorn stimmt de
france verkürzte porsche mitarbeitern
douglas verkaufte vor
das können wir auch sehr gut vorstellen
trauen parfüm arbeitet im douglas
mitarbeiterin genau vielleicht wird sich
auch parfüm recht daran leute heute mag
nicht der beschreibung wie drüben werden
kann aber völlig anders video abchecken
bis zum nächsten mal
weil es da wenn ihr wisst wie es geht
und obendrauf und